Marie-Pier Mercier.
- C'était pas clair
qu'il fallait rembourser.
- Vinct t Desbiens a reçu
il y a quelques jours une
lettre de Service Canada.
Il fait partie des centaines
de milliers de Canadiens qui
doivent rembourser en totalitéor
versement de PCU.
VINCENT DESBIENS, journaliste
pour Journal Métro
- Il fallait le dire à la base
s'il fallait rembourser. C'est
sûr que les gens auraient fait
plus attention à ces montants-là
aussi.
- ... est-il écrit
dans sa lettre.
Deux ans plus tard, Vincent
Desbiens comprend que ce premier
paiement était un prêt.
- C'est vraiment beaucoup
comme somme, surtout là,
en ces temps-ci où est-ce
qu'on sait, avec l'inflation,
t'sais, c'est pas falele
non plus pour se loger, tout ça.
Puis là, à la veille des
vacances, recevoir une lettre
comme ça, c'est jamais
bien le fun, là.
- Dans un mmmmuniqué de presse
passé sous le radar en novembre
dernier, Service Canada écrivait
que les Canadiens qui ont fait
une demande de PCU avant le
14 juin 2020 seraient contactés
pour les informer de leur dette.
Ceux toutefois qui ont reçu
de la PCU tout l'été ont pu
commencer à rembourser
le paiement anticipé à même
leurs cotisations. Les partis
d'opposition accusent
le gouvernement d'avoir manqué
de transparence et de clarté.
LUC BERTHOLD, lieutenant
politique pour le Québec PCC
- Jamais dans les messages, dans
les publicités qu'on a entendus,
c'était : "Allez chercher voee
prêt de PCU, le gouvernement
est là pour vous aider."
NATHALIE SINCLAIR-DESGAGNÉ,
députée bloquiste
- Le bon côté, esest que ça
a été fait vite. Mais le mauvais
côté, c'est que ça a été
vite fait mal fait.
- Dans son avis de paiement,
le gouveemement donne
aux personnes touchées 30 jours
pour rembourser. La lettre de
Vincent Desbiens a été produite
le 19 juin; il l'a toutefois
rereçue le 9 juillet. Ça lui
laisse donc 10 jours pour payer.
- Je suis tombé des nues
quand j'ai appris ça!
- Le gouvernement met
beaucoup de pression alors
que le gouvernement, lui,
a pris deux ans avant
d'exiger le remboursement
de ces sommes-là.
- Au moins quelques mois,
par exemple d'ici la fin
de l'année, ça serait plus
raisonnable que 30 jours
en plein été.
- Les contribuables touchés
doivent contacter Service Canada
pour établir des modalités d
paiement avec le gouvernement.
Les décisions seront donc prises
au cas par cas. Cela augmentera
le fardeau administratif de
l'organisme, qui titite déjà
les demandes de passeports.
Ici Marie-Pier Mercier,
Radio-Canada, Québe